u.s secretary of state mike pompeo made
a special trip to u.n headquarters to
formally accuse iran
of violating the 2015 nuclear deal
in a letter submitted to the security
council president he argues iran has
been enriching uranium
and supplying weapons to proxy militias
in the middle east
it's an attempt to trigger u.n
procedures that would lead to the
automatic reinstatement of sanctions
this process will lead to those
sanctions coming back into effect 30
days from
today our message is very very simple
the united states will never allow the
world's largest state sponsor of
terrorism to freely buy and sell
planes tanks missiles and other kinds of
conventional weapons
these u.n sanctions will continue the
arms embargo
the so-called snapback provision was
part of the deal negotiated five
years ago there's just one problem the
u.s
withdrew from the deal in 2018
it's not triggering a snapback snapback
can be triggered by a country
by a country which is a participant of
the jcpoa
which u.s is not iran like russia
says the u.s move is illegal in the act
of a bully
that nothing is going to happen in 30 or
31 days
because the u.s has to enjoy the support
of the security council
which does not exist the u.s position
is being ridiculed in the security
council the united states has put its
european
allies on the security council in a very
awkward position they didn't speak
publicly but issued a statement saying
they
cannot support the us's unilateral move
because they want to preserve the
international nuclear deal
that is as long as the iranians hold up
their end of it
the one thing that could actually turn a
lot of the europeans
back to the u.s side in these
discussions would be
on serious provocations by iran
i think that what we're likely to see is
the iranians
who know the us electoral calendar
simply wait
it could make for uncomfortable
relations in the security council
at least until november kristin salumi
al-jazeera
the united nations